hello everyone and welcome to an
absolute Thriller of a game from the
final round of the uh US Women's
Championship it is a game between uh
Irina Crush uh Grand Master Irina crush
and feeding Master Jennifer you Arena
crush is an eight-time Women's U.S
champion and Jennifer you is a one-time
uh women's Women's U.S Champion she won
the title in 2019 and she is also this
year's uh 2022 uh us girls Champion so
she's now going for her second title
this year and uh it was uh quite quite
an interesting tournament Irina Crush
was undefeated the entire tournament she
even defeated Jennifer you in their
classical game but Jennifer defeated
more opponents so in the end they both
had nine points out of 13 and they went
into tie break so after uh the
tournament has been played two Blitz
Games will be played and then if the two
Blitz Games are are a draw or if each
wins one then they go into Armageddon
and this is the Armageddon game that we
are going to show uh the the blitz tie
breaks ended by Jennifer winning the
first game and then Irina retaliating in
the second one and now this is the
Armageddon game so let's dive straight
into it because I mean what happens in
this game is absolutely unbelievable so
uh let's check it out so Irina has the
white pieces and she opens with Knight
to F3 she goes for the reti opening
Ponte D5 uh we have G3 now going for the
king's Indian attack and pawn to G6 both
of them are ready to theme here to their
Bishops and Castle King side so Bishop
G2 Bishop G7 and King side castles we
have Pawn to E5 grabbing the full Center
and now Pawn to D3 ready to undermine
the center later on uh we have Knight to
the E7 uh Knight beta D2 and now we have
castles King Side by Jennifer we have
Pawn to E4 striking in the center and
now Pawn to D4 this is a fairly known
position I'd beat the C6 is a known move
here knight uh Pawn to D4 is um uh very
very rare so here at night the E1 are
preparing the strike in the a strike
against the center with Pawn to F4
Knight beat the C6 and now Pawn to F4
and interestingly this is a known
position the position has been reached
in the Yugoslavian Championship 1960
between dragulub minich and the dragon
of chirich where dragons won a very nice
game and in that game a pawn to F5 was
played but in this game uh truly
unbelievable movies played and that is
the move from the thumbnail and that is
Bishop to G4 we can even do it in slow
motion look at this uh Bishop to G4
attacking the White Queen and now you
are wondering uh okay what happens if
the queen captures the bishop exactly
that the queen just captures the bishop
so for some reason uh Jennifer
overlooked an entire piece here and it
wouldn't be it wouldn't be that
incredible if she already didn't do it
once in this tournament and against the
exact same opponent she blundered the
bishop against Arena Crush in their
classical game or maybe it was a
sacrifice I mean it looks uh it does uh
you know drag the queen away from the
center of the board to the queen side if
you've seen the game and okay it could
be considered a sacrifice battle and all
uh just uh a nice Bishop blunder and
here okay this one was a straight out
Wonder uh Jennifer said in an interview
after the game uh that she even asked
the Arbiter uh Chris bird uh you know
maybe she didn't ask maybe she just
looked at him or something like that and
then he was like no you have to play it
I mean you you dropped the bishop uh
it's not like she just picked it up and
then she had to put it somewhere she
picked it up and then she put it on G4
attacking the queen so of course the
move had to be played uh if you think
about it instead of Bishop G4 Bishop to
E6 is a perfectly valid move so she just
picked up the bishop she could have put
it on E6 and everything it's fine but
okay Bishop to G4 and now Queen
characters on G4 and what do you do uh
in a situation like this uh okay since
you guys already probably know that um
Jennifer is the the US Women's Champion
uh she said in an interview after the
game that it's kind of crazy two and a
half weeks of work comes down to a few
seconds and now she could resign I mean
you should resign you're playing against
the Grand Master and you've just
blundered a piece so the only reasonable
thing to do is to resign but of course
that's not what happens here the only
reasonable thing to do is to continue
this is Armageddon there is no increment
so you have to fight uh maybe maybe you
know your opponent just runs on attack
runs out of time because white has to
win this game a draw is insufficient
it's okay Queen captures and G4 and pawn
to F5 attacking the queen queen back to
E2 and now Queen to D7 so can she
complicate can't she get anything out of
this game we have Knight E to F3 uh just
improving the the the position of the
Knight Rook eat a rook 8 to E8 and now F
captures an E5 Knight captures on E5 and
Irina of course a very very happily
Trace pieces as she is up a piece so
Knight captures Bishop captures e
captures on F5 even allowing The Rook to
sort of X-ray the White Queen but
there's the bishop and the knight in
between you don't have to worry about
that Knight captures an F5 and now
Knight E4 and okay we have Pawn to B6
taking away the C5 Square from the
Knight also preparing C5 with Bishop to
D2 preparing to bring the other Rook
into the game and now Pawn to C5 with
Rook to F2 uh preparing to double up on
the f file and Rook the E7 uh Jennifer
wants to double up on the E file as well
you're done material you do not want to
contest whites Rooks on the f file and
you don't want to trade Rooks in general
or anything so Rook 8 to F1 and now Rook
F to E8 and now Bishop to H3 a very
nasty move uh not allowing the Knight to
move the queen is on D7 but also you're
just threatening to pick up the Knight
to win some pawns maybe bring the queen
into the game so how can Jennifer
continue this okay Rook to F7 and now
comes spawn to G4 here you could
consider a bishop H6 or Bishop captures
on F5 uh anything is winning here for
white because you're just up too much
material she goes for Pawn to G4 which
all which is also very nice you want to
move the knights you want to capture on
F7 so here here we have Knight to D6 and
now what do you play here it's such a
such a fine position where you could you
could still play like Bishop H6 you
could capture on D6 you could capture an
F7 so these are all valid moves uh
Knight captures on D6 is played in the
game and now it seems like okay you can
capture an F2 you can capture on D6 you
can capture with the bishop and D6 open
up and attack towards the White Queen
but Jennifer manages to find a move that
seems to be the most complicated to
handle uh uh under time pressure she
plays Bishop captures on H2 with check
and now again what do you play here and
I I'm really asking you that what do you
play here feel free to pause the video
and win the game for for Irina uh while
I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not touching
the bishop with the King and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
the winning movies will captures on H2
you will still be winning if you just
sidestep with the King but uh you will
not be winning if you play King captures
the point is if Rook captures an H2 Rook
captures Sunny too uh you will just play
Knight captures on F7 and now it doesn't
matter what the black plays if Rook
captures on H2 you first save the Knight
Knight to H6 with check King G7 King
captures on H2 and now you have a bishop
a bishop a rook and the Knight for a
queen of course this is completely
winning there are no tricks here Rook to
F7 is coming this is game over so that's
what you should play however in the game
King captures an H2 was played and now
we have uh well probably what Irina saw
under under extreme time pressure was
that once she gives up the queen she can
play Knight captures on F7 and now after
root captures and have to check real
captures it's a similar position to what
we already discussed uh in that position
tonight was an H6 but yeah I mean still
three pieces and a rook for a queen of
course completely winning but she missed
Queen captures on D6 with check and now
we we're gonna get a similar possession
only uh you will not have three pieces
in a rook you will have two pieces and a
rook for the queen which is great but
not as as potent so here King the H1 and
just Rook captures on E2 Rook captures
an E2 and now Queen to D5 with check
Queen to G3 is better but uh I mean this
is Armageddon Queen D5 checking the G1
Rook captures on F1 and the bishop
captures on F1 and now you have this
position where uh Jennifer has a queen
and Irina has a Bishop's pair in the
rook and of course a bishop pair is
sometimes enough to fight the queen but
a bishop pair and The Rook that's just
uh that that's just Overkill so uh but
still white has to win a draw is not
enough a draw means a win for Jennifer
so Queen to F3 Pawn to G5 saving the
pawn also the pawn is very nicely placed
here uh Queen G4 check Rook the G2 now
Queen to the D1 and now we have Bishop
to F4 not even allowing the capture of
the C2 pawn queen to F3 and now Rook to
F2 so now it's only time to mount an
attack against the black king and
hopefully somehow Checkmate him Queen G4
check Bishop to G2 with Queen to D1
check and King to H2 the only uh thing
uh left for Jennifer is the is to play
complicated moves play them really fast
to make the position as complicated as
possible and try and flag Irina uh just
for for her to lose on time so Queen to
E1 we Bishop the D5 with check King to
G7 and now Bishop to G3 threatening a
nice Discovery here to win the black
queen so Queen back to E8 and here we
have King to G2 another beautiful
position where you can end the game in
great style but time pressure is time
pressure here look at this Rook F7 check
and okay King H7 how do you continue
this look at this Rook f8 check
beautiful stuff uh Queen has the capture
uh if you go to G7 uh of course it
doesn't matter you you just lose the
queen but if Queen captures an f8 then
Bishop to E5 look at this the the bishop
pair from Hell Rides Again uh incredible
stuff you will have to give up the Queen
Bishop captures King captures and of
course you will be able to win this end
game if you have the time but time is
um time is a commodity here so Queen to
E8 we have King to G2 now comes spawn to
H5 obviously Jennifer saw the threat
here and she freed up the H7 Square for
her King Rook to F7 check and now King
the h8 now this is no longer an option
because Queen can capture and after
Bishop E5 check you have the H7 Square
for your king So King the F1 Queen the
E3 with Rook the f8 check King to G7
Rook Dev 7 check and King to h a
Jennifer very happy with the repetition
of moles she only needs a draw to win
Armageddon Bishop to F2 Queen to C1 with
check with Bishop to E1 and queen
captures on G5 now white is objectively
no longer winning so here Bishop to E4
Queen to G4 and now Bishop to F2 we have
Queen to D1 checking the G2 Queen to G4
check King to H2 and now King the G8
attacking the white rook and now Rook to
F3 preparing Rook to G3 to win the G6
Pawn but here H4 was played uh taking
away the G3 Square from the Y truck and
it was also in this position on move 47
that Irina Crush lost on time which
means that Jennifer you wins this game
wins Armageddon and also wins the title
of 2022 US Women's Champion
so really a remarkable game and I mean
okay it's not uh unheard of for for
something like this to be played in an
Armageddon game I mean you like she said
you've already been playing for two and
a half weeks and then uh the the entire
us Championship comes down to an
Armageddon game uh it's it's possible to
to make a move like Bishop to G4 but she
blundered a bishop twice against the
same opponent she also did it against
Irina uh in their in their classical
game which is uh I mean which is just
incredible two two Bishop blunders and
you and you win the title of uh US
Women's Champion that's uh absolutely
absolutely incredible I mean that's uh
that's some fight fighting Spirit uh but
yeah uh something to be uh learned from
this game uh you know even if something
like this happens to you regardless of
how important the event is never resign
just continue playing you know good
things might happen if you always play
the best move your opponent might play
uh you know sometimes the best move
sometimes the sub optimal move but then
in the end you know good things might
happen and here you have uh the the
photo of this moment there you have it
in a Crusher loses on time she has zero
zero zero uh Jennifer uh still left with
a full minute on the clock so like she
said the the tactic after blundering
that Bishop was simply to flag her
opponent and as you can see yeah she was
successful in doing so but the real the
real magic was this bishop captures an
H2 move uh because the the Knight on D6
uh was hanging and uh if we're captors I
mean it's just winning even if you move
the king is just winning but after King
captures then the Knight hangs with the
check and then you pick up the queen so
okay she blunder the bishop she
blundered the knight uh all is well a
very nice game I hope you guys enjoyed
it uh you know completely crazy stuff uh
these are the the final standings so you
can see
um uh oh no sorry she's a she's a woman
Grand Master I don't know why I said the
feeding master
uh yeah that that is really weird why
did I say freedom master I have no idea
uh let me just check something real
quickly ah because her chest 24 profile
where I checked the games says FM but
when you click on our link it says women
Grandmaster yeah okay that that
definitely does make more sense so sorry
about that yeah yeah I wouldn't
Grandmaster uh Jennifer you uh takes the
first place uh Grandmaster Irina Crush
wins wins second place uh Talia
Cervantes William Grandmaster third
place um
fourth place thought of abrahamian uh
fifth place okay tied for fifth place
with Alice Lee and Megan Lee uh then you
have in eighth place uh Guru began
tokiryanova then uh
Sophie moris Suzuki Nazi Pakistan and
um
in last place
uh so yeah there we have it that's the
game those were uh the standings hope
you guys enjoyed that very very nicely
done I mean
uh truly something you don't see every
day but yeah take something from this
even if you blunder a piece regardless
of how important the event uh keep keep
playing play the best moves and you you
might still win
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
ravishing reptiles YouTube Trevor
Terrace luxeminarian chakrapani Allen
psycho and listerpan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day